micro thanks for joining us Tucker
thanks for having me
so you spent a lot of your adult life
watching men work what they do how long
they do it why they do it tell us what
happens when men can't work when they're
out of work when they're idle and can't
provide what happens to men well your
soul slips out of you somehow or another
you know it's the frog in the boiling
water nothing good happens but the bad
things that happen as a direct result
unfold in a kind of disaster scenario
you become disengaged
you've become emasculated you start to
ask yourself a whole lot of questions
you can't possibly answer and then if it
gets bad it turns in on itself and you
become resentful and you look for
someone to blame and ultimately you
square off sometimes against your own
family sometimes against your co-workers
sometimes against yourself Longway
saying nothing good it's a disaster as
you just pointed out not just for the
unemployed man but for everyone around
them and for the society itself so given
that and I think that's clearly true
you've got seven million men of working
age out of the workforce now and nobody
talks about it it seems like something
approaching a social crisis why isn't
that in the news more I think because we
can't decide who to blame right I mean
it's not news unless there's a bad guy
so we need a villain you know we got to
have somebody in a black hat and we look
around there's there's no shortage of
potential villains but the hard truth
I'm afraid in my view and again I I'm
not an expert in any of it but I I think
that a lot of what's happened is
self-inflicted you know I think that men
becoming somewhat disconnected from
whatever version of manhood they espouse
I think that happens because of
relationships with their dad with their
grandfather
you know grandfathers aren't around
anymore we talk a lot about the role of
fathers obviously that's been fractured
but it's extraordinary really when you
think about the the safety net a kid had
growing up there was a dad there and
there was a grandfather there and there
was inertia and there were a
lot of things that the kid could look to
not just for ideas and virtues but for
proof you know so that's gone and that's
not just a problem for the individual
it's a problem I think if you think a
culture has an identity if you think of
society as a as a soul these are the
enemies of those things there's no
question about it do you think that we
value work as an inherent virtue as a
society no no I don't i think i think
that we have identified work as the
proximate cause of our dissatisfaction
and i think you don't have to look far
to find endless examples look the
best-selling books right now in the
self-help section and in general claimed
to have the solution for how you can
work less most of the commercials on TV
ask a tacit question you know how could
you be happier and the answer of course
is retire a little sooner or work 35
instead of 40 hours you know the TV
shows that are typically valued tend to
embrace notions of shortcuts you know in
a thousand different ways I believe as a
society we've made the case that the
enemy of your happiness is your damn job
and if you can only have less of that
all these other things in some perverse
zero-sum game would equal out and you
would smile more
look I know it's hackneyed and I know
we've talked about it before but this is
Horatio Alger stuff this is being
suspicious of of immediate gratification
it's taking the long view and most
importantly in my view you know we can
control how we define a good job there's
a lot of stuff we can't control but our
culture has made it very very clear that
some kinds of work are less desirable
than others and once we set the table
that way then we start to look at some
kinds of education as being more
important than others next thing you
know you got 1.5 trillion dollars in
student loans you've got 6 million jobs
available right now that involve
training and not a four-year degree and
you've got a whole generator
of kids who are nicely educated for jobs
that don't exist anymore with a big fat
pile of debt they can't pay back because
we lent them a bunch of money we didn't
have in the first place it ain't great
so I gotta say almost all the happy and
successful people I know work and love
to work so maybe there's something at
least for men there's something about
working that makes you happy just the
act of working dude gets true I think so
I do think it's true but but I think I
think the lie like the big underlying
bright and shiny lie is the idea that
what you do is the thing that will
either make you happy or unhappy that's
not what you just said what what you
said is the business of working has an
underlying inherent value to it and I do
believe deeply that that's a hundred
percent true if it were true that
certain jobs made certain people unhappy
or made everybody unhappy then obviously
everybody in that job would be miserable
but right you know if there's it if
there's one enduring lesson from Dirty
Jobs it's the fact that those people as
a group we're having a better time and
we're more connected to their work than
the vast majority people I know who make
great white collar livings it's just an
inconvenient truth if you'll pardon the
the bromide but it's out there and and
there's a lot of hope in it you know if
you can find people doing something that
you were told is supposed to make you
miserable but they are somehow
prospering and happy you're gonna have
to square that the evidence demands a
verdict then looks at good news and all
of this is there's a lot of evidence out
there that's positive
the average lumberjack that you
interviewed on your show always seemed a
lot happier than the average corporate
lawyer I know which is kind of it's it's
like being in on some sort of joke it
really it truly is I mean we could talk
more but it's it's basically a Band of
Brothers and it's the feeling you get
when you know that whatever it is you're
doing matters of course you have to get
paid but you also have to know that
you're doing something worthwhile
exactly micro that was great thank you
any time